for many in russia this letter has  become symbolic of what their government  calls a special military operation in  ukraine seen on many of their armoured  vehicles it's used as an identifying  mark to differentiate it from others  because to many in the rest of the world  the letter has become a symbol of  aggression  and in some eu countries for example  lithuania there is growing concern about  how the symbol could be used or misused  in germany too there are calls to outlaw  those who display the letter with the  intent to glorify aggressive war  laws that ban such behavior do already  exist with nazi era symbols like the  swastika and the letters ss prohibited  now several german states are saying  they intend to prosecute anyone who  displays the letter zed  in the same way  dominic kane al jazeera berlin